I've seen you do some very good dramatic
acting work you're a fine actor thank
you III say that you know in all
seriousness what's interesting is that
the character Berry is he gets
interested in acting and he's a bad
actor so you're a good actor who has to
play a bad actor is that difficult well
not for a good actor known now you know
what I'd watch is I love to crime shows
like the ID Network or you know that
stuff it's like snaps there's so called
snap that I love and just watching the
reenactments on that is pretty great
that's like good that's where you can
study about a head acting yeah where
it's just like their marriage was going
awful and it's like where's the food
[Laughter]
yeah you know it's always kind of like
listen honey I I think we shouldn't have
killed your sister the cops are on to us
this is a gold mine yeah you observed
real acting classes when you're
preparing yeah for this role what did
you take anything away from seeing real
acting classes that you that you used in
the show yeah Alec Berg and I watched a
guy there's a scene in the in the first
episode where Henry Winkler who plays
the acting acting coach yells at an
actress played by Sarah Goldberg and he
makes her cry and we watched a guy do
that he yelled at this actress to get
her to a place and she started crying
and was just terrible to her and then
she cried and then afterward she was so
thankful and was like thank you for
getting me there and everything and I
was like I'm in like at least ten movies
no one has ever done that to me
no-one's ever yelled at you know judd
apatow in trainwrecks i like you're an
idiot
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a killer jet go online it right
now
we'll wait yeah
[Applause]
you